- All right, so let's end the hour
with something cool I've found
on the pages of social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
So what started as a
passion for vintage clothes
for two young men has turned into
a full-blown thriving business.
And it's not just about
selling old school threads
but it's also about giving
the entire new school style
and inspiring others to do the same.
It's good for business, it's
also good for the environment,
and TikTok is going crazy for the looks.
Check this out.
(upbeat playful music)
(audience cheering)
So cool and it's so throwback
nineties and I'm into it.
We have these entrepreneurs on the line,
watching on Tampa Bay's MOR-TV
from Vintage Stock Reserve,
let's say hi to Tommy and Jordan.
(audience cheering)
- Hey Kelly.
- What's up, y'all?
I'm so impressed by y'all, you're so cool.
So Jordan, why don't you start.
Explain more of how this got started.
- So it all started when
my grandma introduced me
to the thrift shop.
The first time I went in there,
I was shocked with what
I was able to find,
and the unique items, it was just unreal.
So when me and Tommy met, it
became a go-to hobby for us.
Any chance we had, we
were in the thrift stores
to see what we could find.
And before you know it,
we accumulated a collection
that was bigger than us.
So we decided to share our
collection with the community
and start doing local pop-up markets.
Every week, people were lined up
to see what we had to offer next.
And we decided to teach ourselves to sew,
and that's when our upcycling journey
began to grow on TikTok.
- That is so cool.
So Tommy, you developed a
huge following on TikTok.
So tell us about your upcycle challenges.
- Yeah, so, when we first got on TikTok,
everyone was just doing these dance trends
and we wanted to switch it
up and do something new.
So we started showing the
process of upcycling on TikTok
to promote a more sustainable
space in the fashion industry.
One of our early videos
actually, is us reworking
a vintage Mickey Mouse bed
sheet into a bucket hat.
And that video now has
over 28 million views.
Another one of our popular videos
is us taking a green and gray sweater,
mixing and mashing it together
to create a fun, unique item.
Now, Jordan and I do something
called the Upcycle Challenge
which is where we go to a thrift shop
with the budget of $10 and 10 minutes
to find things we normally wouldn't buy
and we spin a wheel to decide
what clothing item we're gonna make.
And it's pretty much a
competition between us
to see who can make the cooler item,
and it's up to the audience
to vote in the comments
who does the best job.
And through doing all of
this, we're able to educate
and inspire others to get
into sustainable fashion.
- This is so rad you guys.
I love it. Thank you so much, Tommy.
Thank you, Jordan,
for the inspiration.
(audience cheering)
I'm liking your post right now.
(heart dings)
And that's not all, fellas.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show",
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like you.
So they're gonna give you
$1,000. How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Wow. Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] I love you guys.
- That means a lot.
- [Kelly] I can't wait to see more videos.
Keep inspiring us, all right?
- [Jordan] Thanks, Kelly.
- Thank you having us.
- All right.
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Hillary Duff, Benjamin Levy Aguilar,
Reed, Pat, and Drake Milligan.
Y'all have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.